[Music]
after months of distance education the
clark county school district now has a
plan for getting kids
back into the classroom thank you for
joining us tonight at 11 i'm bryan
loftis
and i'm denise valdez ccsd's plan is
actually a hybrid model so it's a
combination of at home
and in person learning oracle mana
joining us now live in the studio
tonight to explain how it will all look
for students orca
well denise and brian this 250 page plan
released tonight
by ccsd really shows how much thought is
going into this
now under the hybrid model students will
start getting back in the classroom
in january it's important to note that
this is just a proposal it'll be voted
on later this week
and teachers and parents i spoke to have
differing opinions on it
i would love to go back in the classroom
the clark county school district is now
closer to making that happen ccsd
releasing this plan to transition to the
hybrid model after months of remote
learning
students would be divided into three
groups two would do a mix of in-person
and at-home learning and the third would
do full-time distance education and now
for the first time we have return dates
on december 1st all employees would go
to work locations on january 4th
students in pre-k to second grade 6th
grade and 11th to 12th grade would begin
hybrid learning and on january 11th all
other grades would start the proposed
plan details capping classroom sizes to
50 percent
and it even provides visual aids on how
to space out desks to adhere to social
distancing guidelines
additionally no playground equipment
water fountains or field trips would be
allowed some after school activities
would be ok
including no contact or minimal contact
sports social distancing and better air
flow is recommended on school buses mask
wearing and extra sanitation would also
be required even with these measures not
everyone is convinced
i appreciate the plan but at the same
time i'm definitely concerned especially
with the way that the numbers are
getting out of control again
also a concern for many the impact of
distance learning on the mental health
and academic progress of students
ccsd noting an increased student suicide
rate and falling grades some parents say
that needs to change
i would love for the kids to go back to
school again
in a very safe environment that's safe
and healthy and hygienic for them and
the employees
but nothing really beats face-to-face
learning and being in the same room as
the person you're learning from
now it's important to note that several
charter and private schools in the
valley have been doing everything from
a hybrid model to full in classroom
learning for months
now the ccsc board of trustees will vote
on the district's plan
at their meeting this thursday night